mais l'homme de la rue qui lui ne joue
pas en bourse se ressent peut-être une
sorte de désenchantement
le gouvernement lui a demandé de serrer
sa ceinture d'un cran il l'a fait mais
il n'a pas l'impression que cela lui a
rendu la vie plus facile
le marché commun est-il responsable de
cet état de fait
les anglais sont divisés mais ils sont
chaque mois plus nombreux à regretter
l'adhésion de la grande bretagne au
marché comme 44% contre
en juin 40 9% en octobre monsieur madame
white des anglais bien tranquille
partage cet avis pluie et responsable
des ventes dans une usine
il gagne 2000 francs par mois et son
salaire n'a pas été augmenté depuis
trois ans or on a l'impression que les
anglais finalement refusé un peu cette
centrale marché commun simplement on ne
veut pas dans le marché commun les
anglais n'aiment pas aller qu'il ya ici
en longueur une certaine indépendance on
aime penser soi même créer soi-même sa
façon de vivre
ils ont l'impression que le marché
commençait peut-être obligés de faire
quelque chose qui ne veut pas faire oui
détruit l'héritage c'est une idée plus
indépendante est une star mais je crois
que c'est papon douce et pour eux les
folies du général thiam pour les jeunes
c'est peut-être mieux ça dans le marché
commun qu'est ce qui a changé pour vous
depuis que vous êtes en train de marcher
demain par exemple les prix ont
tellement manqué qu on ne peut plus
avoir recours
le matin on ne peut pas voir des
collectes la grille ou des gobelins prix
de tomates lé problème nous avons
beaucoup plus de problèmes mais je ne
sais pas si c'est la faute du marché
commun mais enfin on lui met tout sur le
dos et ça me donne l'occasion de rallye
[Musique]